son premier album avait créé la surprise
2 millions d'exemplaires vendus et une
Victoire de la musique pour Carla Bruni
qui nous revient aujourd'hui avec un
nouveau disque cette fois-ci 11 chansons
en anglais 11 poèmes Olivier linudza
matthie
bden ambiance étrange à la tombée de la
nuit en plein cœur de Paris le refuge de
la Belle au bois
[Musique]
chantant
un matin une bonne la chanteuse anglaise
marancien top
modamake coup
deoudres anglais
[Musique]
am la chanteuse en musique 11
poèmes les poésies sont sont c'est comme
si c'était des chansons avec leur propre
musique incorporée donc ce qui m'attire
dans ces poésies c'est leur rythme leur
musique l'extrême solitude aussi dont
elle témoigne et l'extrême
humanité tout comme son premier album
paru en 2002 Carla BRI a confié la
réalisation de son nouveau disque à un
ami l'ancien membre du groupe Téléphone
Louis
bertigac je vais vous donner un secret
le son des des percussions de car brun
c'est c'est 50 % de
ça momentanément l'amoureuse Desmo a mis
l'écriture de côté c'est pas vraiment un
choix c'est juste que je réussissais pas
à écrire en français je crois parce que
j'étais encore en train de digérer le
premier
disque je me Gour parce que je la fais
souvent demi plus ha il faut pas je me
sentais pleine de musique et finalement
ces poèmes ont été un petit peu les SOeS
sur lequel j'ai mis ma
[Musique]
musique elle a vendu 2 million de son
album
précédentuse des plus grands
photographes
fille d'une grande famille italienne
vieessemble roman car elle se une poésie
h h
h